hi slugs it's your girls we're all three
here today this episode is a wild ride
and i am announcing some tour dates i'm
coming to
portland and
san francisco and new york city get
tickets at esteronice.com and also check
out sleepoverbyaster.com
for my wonderful clothing line guys the
road has been freaking amazing please
keep coming back i love meeting all you
guys i it's an honor to make you laugh
you can see me next at comedy works in
denver colorado then i'll be at the
laugh out loud comedy club in san
antonio october 23rd
22nd through 23rd i'm gonna be at
skankfest in houston plano texas house
of comedy november 11th through 14th the
irvine improv december 2nd austin texas
cap city december 9th through 11th uh
i'll be at bananas comedy club in
december 16th through 18th and
there's a lot more dates on my website
go to annieletterman.com pick up a shirt
you guys have been rocking them i love
it thank you guys so much
peace
[Music]
oh it's so funny this sound is so like
the suction release like it's the clip
out and then when you take this off it's
like
it sounds like that like it made this if
you put that on your lips would it like
make them bigger
wait but this is actually how i look i
feel like i look so hot as dave you do
look dare i say the hottest you've ever
looked it's
are you attracted i have never been
not my taste in any outfit it's not
really the outfit issue
skin wait
i am so excited right i have more to
show you why are todd's pants tight on
you i'm just gonna say by the way
literally i was gonna says i used to
dress like a boy ever and so on i was
like i've never looked hotter because it
hangs off your hips
these are like
high-waisted pain i have like camel toe
in my boyfriend's
doctor oh wait i have more i have more i
had him dry his tattoos on me [ __ ] i
woke his ass up with sharpies i was like
wake up in
time to draw and then i was criticizing
it at every moment i was like that's
really ugly you look a little bit like a
like a bears fan on snl like you're
going to say duh bears
well in that sentiment i was like he is
asian and how tempting was that
it was almost like you know the day i
get cancelled
we would have given you a pass i think i
would maybe because you're like an
honorary asian at this point i would
have needed uh 99 out of 100 asians that
we lined up to say it was okay before i
did it yeah and i would need them to
sign and it would have to be let's be
real i mean i've been pocahontas before
is that bad
yeah because you're not native i'm not
native but it's really hard to believe
i just want to every time i see you even
if you work put a feather right in your
[ __ ] head that's even worse right
like being sorta like sort of almost
looking like one and then like
imagine if any always says if if i was
in the industry if i was an actor to
just be like completely ambiguous and
yeah yeah you're gonna say what i am but
i feel like it's kind of [ __ ] up well
that's like our friend jenna who's an
actress and she i feel like she always
like
things have changed a lot in the last 10
years but before that people always
thought she was indian and like that
that's how she would like she would get
cast as someone indian but she always
showed up with a bindi
[Laughter]
um okay there's another i take my tits
down which i know was maybe not
necessary
no that cannot be wishful
let me see
but i couldn't help but make it a little
hot you know what i mean what have you
done
you're the only person in the world who
would make titty tape look hot wait whoa
whoa whoa is there tape on directly on
your nipple
annie i gotta help you out of this well
then i'll be able to um pluck my nipple
hair at the same time
oh by the way i had to take my abs off
because usually i have abs so i paint i
painted them off because i have real abs
and because
[Laughter]
so today we are dressed as our as our
boyfriends esther i feel like you should
have to wear the mask the whole time
you've never looked hotter
i love this look on you i i feel so
[ __ ] hot i just feel hot don't you
you don't see it you just are a lesbian
it's like really weird it's like just
dress like you want you could just dress
like this this is how i feel
off like and then i got his box dave's a
boxer guy are you wearing boxers yeah
lots of briefs
boxer briefs
you guys already know let's let's let's
not pretend we don't know what bobby's
underwear looks like bob ross is that
bob ross
okay that's cool wait let's see your
underwear
[Music]
oh god that's so cool the longest i've
never seen bobby in long and long
underwear
but these are he's he's this or his
these are he's
she is um
as a classic man in his 40s is this
dave's tattoo it's no you know from the
last episode oh by the way wait can we
talk about the last episode first of all
you have my arch nemesis on
by the way rick glassman does not follow
me on instagram and i give him very good
comments it's oh there's a grudge from
one side
i know that is so juicy and he will be
confronted on this because your girl's
funny there's no reason to not love it i
this is what i wrote he said he posted a
thing on his you can't not respond to us
he posted a thing on his instagram that
was like hey do you guys know any
holocaust survivors i'd love to
interview them on my podcast and i wrote
under it
they've been through enough read them
alone
oh are you not that's i that's
undeniably the funniest thing someone
could ever write it's like no like no it
got like all these likes no responses
because he's got it he has a grudge with
me and it's like listen we're both on
the spectrum you can't play your little
autistic thing with me [ __ ] okay
we're both i went to occupational
therapy okay i got rubbed up and down
with a weird vibrating thing with the
horse brush
yes and i got brushed at home my mom had
to brush me with a surgical brush so
surgical brush yeah like the brushes
they use in their hands
i will say there's a large appetite out
there a large appetite for a for rick
and annie in the same room yeah i know
but but listen i'm gonna tell you it's
not coming from me because listen
i think i know what the grudge is but
you know we'll talk about it when he
comes back on and we do a lingerie too i
literally get oh and then you do
lingerie you look hot and then for me
you're like hey dress like a dude
you're like no we'll save the one word
you're looking at the wrong person also
don't look this way george the
mastermind george himself george kimmel
george didn't want to get a boner with
you guys did leprechauns without me that
seems unfair is that what we look like
leprechauns why well do you want to know
why we did that because he's saying
leprechauns
sorry esther's a fairy right now
it does look good it does actually look
good like it's there's something to it
it's so sad that you're like so
desperate you want to look like you went
to harvard i was like no way it's like
we know this [ __ ] [ __ ] dropped out
of you you look like you do listen to
wilco i yes he loves by the way i did
shows in um
in chicago and you were missed oh my god
how was it did you eat anything good no
i was in the [ __ ] hotel getting room
service i was like
oh you didn't get pizza no you don't eat
cheese well i mean i will but i just was
like
i had just done my ayahuasca weekend so
it was like the day after i was like uh
i don't think i can eat cheese ever
again now i'm like wait i want to talk
about this um i want to know what um
what visions came through um during your
last ayahuasca
trip i had a vision of esther eating out
another girl no you didn't nobody got
excited
you're like what did it look like say
more
um no i didn't want to do the weekend as
we know you guys very hesitant why not
because i'm having too many shamans i
have too many shamans in my opinion
she's a dilemma
problem in your life where you just have
too many shamans i know that i'm doing
well financially because i have a shaman
problem it's like i'm killing it
one shaman you can still be broke all
right two shamans your money's going
places is okay
your assets are growing i am
manifesting some stuff so okay so
one shaman was like do the shamans get
along well they don't know i have one
that's a divorce shaman and one's a gay
gentleman okay and then it's but
they're all so good i love them but one
gentleman i haven't met i just know him
through
his brother-in-law who i do like these
training courses with that are very cool
sky jim fortin but so i love the jim
foreign podcast which you told me about
oh my god are you listening to it not
lately but i i should but you told me
about it last year and when i was
listening to i thought it was actually
beautiful did i give you a tool to
change your life yes but i did not use
it you did that's very typical esther
that's okay no but i do like it a lot
well i did this whole like training
program with him for like 14 weeks and
it's like the greatest thing that's ever
happened we need to hear more
but
and it is opening up if you guys want to
join but you have to tell them it's
through me so i go
oh my god this is a business scam it's
not a business no okay wait so
so tell me
about the shamans okay so he has a
shaman that he talks about all the time
jim foreign his brother-in-law's ashamed
then i have my own shaman who's my like
ayahuasca shaman who i like love and
he's amazing what is this uh shaman
certification okay well here's the thing
so my shaman that does he's like a
ayahuasca shaman so he's like trained
and he trained um with these peruvian
guys in brazil
where he lives and he's south african
and so he trained with like the people
that have done it for you know their
families done it for decades and or
hundreds of years whatever and then you
got a real badunka dunk over there
sticking out of your pants
happy trees happy little treats
there's just a real dunker i'm still
working on that root chakra guys
we're gonna talk about my root chakra
i mean there's things i can't even talk
about but uh oh my god
so
okay so then i have the other shaman is
so he's trained that way and he's like
not but he's
he's kind of like becoming like i don't
know he's he's very like excellent and
skilled at this at
at ayahuasca
my
jim forten shaman is
like was born in mexico to a family of
shamans and was like buried to his neck
in dirt and given like
mushrooms when he was nine and like left
in the desert like he's like a he is
like a trained [ __ ] shaman okay
like this guy is like can get in your
mind when you're not there like he's
like he is like a spiritual
thing entity
and um
so they're different but
he randomly i'm in this um like
i have this one program where there's
like a bunch of videos that jim did a
couple years ago so i just like randomly
was like watching a video i don't
remember what the topic was but
someone asked a question about ayahuasca
and he was like guys
don't do ayahuasca and it was like i had
already signed up i was like my plane
ticket i was like wait what why did i
randomly click on this thing that said
why did he what did it say not to do
like because he doesn't want people you
don't want to just go do ayahuasca with
some idiot like someone that doesn't
know what they're doing because you are
like going to another like
like
dimensional dimension i don't know
like you're
you're going to another astral plane
you're like in yeah life death yeah the
the light yeah like it's just you go to
a place that's really wild and he was
just saying you don't want to do it with
someone that's not trained because you
want someone to be able to like put you
back here like you don't want it like
properly yeah because this girl was
saying she was having nightmares and
stuff now i have never not been like 100
into my experiences with ayahuasca where
i'm like i'm going in 100
i'm drinking every cup offered to me i i
love and trust everyone in this
community
and but when i heard that it put this
like seed of doubt in me and then i
started to panic and i was like wait but
i am doing well i don't want to be like
it wasn't i've never done ayahuasca and
like i did this situation where my life
is like very good you know like i was
always looking for something at a
specific thing i was anxiously attached
about a guy which by the way write that
down because i heard
my guy on a [ __ ] podcast one of my
old guys on a podcast explaining some
stuff that was very interesting wait
what i can't wait to tell you
but let me just try to stay on track
should we just stop right now i don't
know
you're you're in charge baby but that's
what i learned because i didn't want to
do the ayahuasca side these voices in my
head from other people and then i was
like in the end when i did the ayahuasca
i was like the lesson was
no more peer pressure no work no more
external
validation no more asking others what i
should do yes this is about listening to
myself what do i really want what do i
really want and i was in it i was
fighting it the first time i was
fighting and i just kept thinking about
which i loved todd i was like oh my god
i'm so in love i love him i love him i
love him i love randy and just like
really feeling like guilty that i wasn't
with them and feeling very homesick but
feeling just so in love with him like
just like
this is my guy i love him
and um
and then
the next night
um
like i drank it and mother ayahuasca
literally like came to me
and
started like trying to peel my nose like
take my nose off and peel my lips off so
that i would like she was trying to kill
my ego like so i wasn't me anymore i was
just like
the light or whatever and i just didn't
want to do it i was like no [ __ ] i
don't want to go this deep like i don't
feel like going this deep i'm like
working on myself here and i don't want
to do it but
and i knew that she was going to make me
do stuff with my parents and i feel like
i've like really worked on like
detaching from
the upset of my parents eventually like
leaving this earth and not completely
obviously i'm gonna be sad and stuff but
i'm really like doing a lot of work on
that
and i was like this [ __ ] [ __ ] is
gonna like find where i'm not fully
there yet yeah so you're not ready to go
there yeah but i but she took me there
anyway i had to kill my parents again i
was like my mom's [ __ ] dead and my
man oh my god
i was like
like what the hell but then i like
called my parents and i was like over
this bucket and i was feeling so like i
missed todd and miss randy i was just
like so homesick and i was like crying
over this bucket did you miss a little
esther and a collider i didn't know you
guys well i did talk to you about it and
we only took in person
but um
but yeah i know that came up too but the
parent thing was like so i'm like over
this bucket and i was like i was crying
and like throw and when you throw up
it's not like
i don't like feel like oh i gotta throw
up whenever i feel like a
sadness or like a
a bad
feeling that i'm working through when
i'm ready i like sit up and it it
literally just it purges out like
like
it really does feel like you're like
getting helped by your ancestors or
whatever so i'm like vomiting it's so
funny i look like this when i'm talking
about this i'm vomiting
into this bucket and i just started
crying i was like i just don't want to
do this alone and then it was like boom
there's like the core belief that's been
killing me like this like
like eternal like
sadness and being alone
and so then i realized like i'm
i have to like call my people with me
because they're a part of me and there's
no way like
it's not just like the tangible earth
you know it's like i have to really
start leveling up and looking at
vibration and knowing that all of my
people are always with me so i like
called my parents to come like be with
me when i was lonely and my mom was like
helping me get water like i looked so
crazy i'm like
like laying down then i'm like grabbing
one like thanks mama
thank you mama
but it was like you know my mom was like
always be with you and my dad was there
too but it was more about my mom this
time
and then um
i also was
i mean there were so many things but i
didn't i only they offer you three cups
throughout the night so
like every two hours like you can come
if you want to go deeper and i didn't
but i i had to go i went to the altar
and i was like crying to my shaman i was
like is it okay that i don't want to
take more and he was like
yes like but i was like this is a thing
like i was like sobbing because i wasn't
like fitting in with everyone everyone
else was doing it and it was just like
but it felt to me i really learned that
it's like braver for me to not do it
sometimes than it is to me for me to do
the thing yeah i want to ask well we
know you think
do less
i wanted to ask you um what about the
guy with the serpent the serpent on the
altar
oh there was a guy who was like shaking
like he was vibrating he was like three
people away from me he was vibrating in
a way that was like i i literally was
like this is a [ __ ] serpent and i was
like what is going on what are you
battling like what are you like i was
like this is a man who's like
something's happening
it was i've never this isn't like a like
this was like a
i i just i i couldn't when you do
ayahuasca um
when you look up right then you're not
hugging the bucket
um are you here or are you completely
departed like are you able to like it's
just like if you have
[ __ ] yeah you have you can go i mean if
the cops came in i have no i i honestly
can't imagine that scenario i love that
word departed
i'm really that's fun
dearly i'm not i'm just departed right
you're no you're nearly departed
but i um yeah but i was thinking i was
really appreciating
um your the work that you do
the extra stuff that you do on the
podcast because i'm kind of out at
serena faster and i do not watch [ __ ]
we do not well yeah no kalila is the
editing mastermind really
like i think about that too she's the
editing mastermind for sure yeah like
which is not a small part like that is
actually the secret to the successful
podcast if you could hear the stuff she
usually says oh yeah i'm sure that we
all believe it's me she really is just
flapping that mouth
but i think we came up with that plan
well before our yeah
yeah you guys are very clear like we are
just gonna show up if that's okay and
i'm like yes that's fine she's you have
always do that right
and we want to give you more of esther's
money
we've decided to give you this is what
we decided you ruined my trip
but wait do you know what his crazy side
note while she is the editing mastermind
she also did you by chance see her full
body in her lingerie outfit no i already
know
it's i it's crazy
i'm really just calling her that but
it's right it's like a different level i
didn't know what we have with her like
this is like our little like just go out
the you know that tick tock where it's
like hello [ __ ]
here comes the [ __ ]
like that's
i'm just worthy
you're the fat she's the [ __ ]
growing up cereal was actually the best
part of my childhood everyone can tell
there's literally nothing that screams i
love cereal more than the shape of your
face
your height your size but why did we
have to give it up because it's full of
sugar and garbagio it's not good for you
and that's why there's one brand that
has changed my life forever hollywood
approved okay magic spoon
zero grams of sugar 13 to 14 grams of
protein and only four net grams of carbs
in each serving and only 140 calories a
serving it's keto friendly gluten free
grain free soy free low carb and gmo
free but did you ever just wake up as a
kid and like sprint down the stairs and
like wait ready for your cart
i know you didn't sprint okay
fair enough i was pushed you guys they
have new flavors too so now not only do
they have cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter the blueberry cinnamon but now
they have cookies and cream and maple
waffle oh my god it's so good subscribe
today to flavors you love and you can
get cereal shipped to your doorstep not
to mention saving more than 25 on every
order you can choose four flavors you
love edit your subscription to switch it
up and keep yourself stocked up on
cereal okay favorite flavors one two
three go fruity yeah i'm gonna say
cookies and cream just sounds right at
mine i'm a frosted gal forever i keep it
simple you guys can go to magicspoon.com
tuesday5
or use our promo code tuesday5ve
spell it out at checkout to get five
dollars off your order and try it today
remember if you subscribe to magic spoon
you get five dollars off on top of the
25 savings from subscribing that's a big
deal and magic spoon is so confident in
their product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember
subscribe and get your delicious
guilt-free cereal on the regular at
magicspoon.com
tuesday5 and use the code tuesday5 spell
it out f-i-v-e
to save big thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring this episode we love you
you guys today's episode is sponsored by
manscaped which is perfect for today i
think manscape the leaders and men's
below the waist grooming it's back to
school time and we want to make sure
your man is packing the essential stab
as best year yet the manscaped fourth
generation performance package is just
that get him the
valedictorian
of ball trimming so he can join two
million men worldwide who trust manscape
by going to manscaped.com
code trash and guys listen not only did
i dress up like my boyfriend but i did
shave my balls just like him and that
was with manscaped
and they look good this package includes
a brand new lawnmower 4.0 and will give
him the confidence to do anything you
desire send him to smoothballs
university to learn a thing or two
i'm okay with hair but just
tame it a little bit all right listen i
remember hooking up with this bartender
in college and i was blowing him in
the bathroom at work
um and
he
at one point i needed to get my sea legs
because i was a little drunk and so i
went over and he started jerking off and
i was like i guess i'll just and he
didn't want me back i was like oh no
that's not a good sign so i just sat
there and it was like i just was pretty
much flossing my teeth with his pubes he
this was before manscape and i'll tell
you i really wish manscape had been
there you guys don't be annie's bathroom
rando with your long-ass pubes and get
manscaped
you guys can get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code trash at
manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
manscape.com this year have your men
graduate with a degree in clean balls
from manscaped oh finally a graduate
here's something you might have missed
from last week's episode as did esther
tell you that without us annie that she
has started taking edibles
the outfit is becoming more
now you're just taking them you are
better
everyone says that i did
i did start taking edibles
and it is weird and i have so much
there's so much all right i can't wait
for us to get [ __ ] up okay oh that's
the plan i'm strictly with the gummies
oh my god i know it's right i can only
imagine how many you take cause they
taste good
she went up to ten
she went up you didn't she go up to ten
yeah are we gonna do a thing where we
see how high we can go no
oh let's not play that game because i
will start speaking korean no
amazing
if i start speaking korean we know i'm
[ __ ] up
now i okay wait so i was thinking what
if we just had like a medic with us my
sister she's a nurse what happened to
you my sister because you're not
actually like you might just freak out
but if you hadn't if you got a nurse
going you're fine
yeah but what are you trying to do
have the most fun we could have okay
just make it i like the sound of that
yeah
but i really i was thinking about you in
the eyes ayahuasca trip i was just
sending you love i was like i don't need
to tell her but i did i'm telling you
he's sending you love
thank you
i want to do something different i want
to be on three different drugs
each of us and see if we
ever align at any point like you can
take a side i could take a psychedelic
you can take an edible no i can drink
you take mushrooms you take an edible
i wonder if we can meet in a place i'm
down i'm super down for that but i also
really want to because will an edible
what does it what what will pot do you
do if you do a lot will you get like
silly fun because that's what i want i
don't want the like a man like i'm just
in my couch like i don't want that you
don't want to be the couch girl from
that ad remember that commercial
where she smoke sweet she's like nothing
happens when i smoke weed nothing
happens and then she's the couch
like will you get fun and silly
yeah okay i never there's never been a
drug that's taken amy is probably fun
and silly in iowa i want i did have some
good ones someone was like taking their
second cup and they're like oh my god my
gag reflex i'm like well good thing i
got rid of that in college you know like
i was doing my jokes and then also like
we all got tested and everything and
this was weeks ago so i didn't get it
but
but part of the ceremony is he like
spits like this like rose what i was
crying laughing like he was spitting in
our faces i was like guys this is like
the opposite of like what has been
happening for the past
did it feel exhilarating to get spat on
those it was amazing
my shaman i'm now in love with my gay
sham and like i really have like very
romantic loving feelings towards him and
i i did offer him sexual favor
he did
i met him on stage he told me was love
at first sight he saw me on stage i was
his favorite i do wonder that sometimes
i feel like at some point in my life i
felt very deeply connected to someone i
probably wasn't sexually connected with
yeah but like i mean romantic feelings
were there i would be like todd you have
to let me as my shaman
i feel something different like i want
to look into this because i feel such a
deep connection with my friend john i
know you're going to make fun of me but
there's nothing romantic and nothing
sexual but it's just like i just like lo
i always i'm like john i love you can i
offer an option yeah it's two gay people
in the closet hanging out
but is that why
like do you know what i'm saying like
you just like i just love you but it's
not sexual romantic i have it sounds
like yours is
that are you not having that with
true
but with a guy it just seems a little
different i have guy friends that i have
no
sexual i mean most of them honestly yeah
most of them really yeah i'm like if i
wanted to [ __ ] with you i would have
[ __ ] you i know i know i have that
policy too okay so
i'll remember more of the ayahuasca trip
in a little bit but i so i'm watching i
was watching a clip of a podcast
and i had one of my uh exes are you
going to say who no but you'll say it to
us right now but give me the look okay
so this was a guy that i had dated
on and off like kind of friend zoned me
really anxiously attached like very gas
lighty situation like really like where
i was like are you [ __ ] playing me
you're [ __ ] playing like i didn't
wasn't into him i was he was we were
like a little flirty
in the beginning when we were friends
and that was like kind of fun but then
he started like holding my hand in
public holding my hand at comedy clubs
which is work and i was like dude no
what are you doing i just broken up with
a comic and a mutual friend of ours
and i and i was like what are you doing
like i this is like really like
it was just like my boundaries were
crossed it was just like why are you
doing this in front of people this is
weird i don't know what the future of
this is i don't feel like coming out as
someone that's like dating you i have my
spidey sense is up that you're playing
me
and he's like no no that's not it i'm
just like you
taking me on a date driving me around
taking me up to his house in the hills
like just really like flattering me just
love bombing me
all this stuff and then um we had like
[ __ ] once and then after we [ __ ] he
oh he was getting texts from he was
dating this actress
which by the way i think he went on one
date with her but he had kept telling me
about this one first friends this
actress he was dating and he would like
be like oh help me get make text her and
stuff in the beginning and i'm like i
don't want to help you text her who
cares
um and then like on our date we had gone
shopping for because i just broke it up
with my boyfriend he's like i need new
clothes so i was like oh i'll take you
shopping i have girlfriend energy took
him shopping like there were all these
like little parts right and i was just
like we're friends we have fun like
whatever maybe we'll bang one time
someday or whatever but nothing like
we're gonna be boyfriend and girlfriend
he um
shows me those texts the first time we
bank so now he's making it like we're
gonna be boyfriend and girlfriend okay
now before we bang it's like there's
been all of this like flirting he's
picking me up we sit in his car for
hours at night he calls me in the
morning we call at night um like hanging
out in his hot tub like there's just
like all of these like it was just like
it feels like it's gearing up we're
starting to be a boyfriend and
girlfriend which i was like i resisted
it but he like he broke down my walls
and
and then when we were banging the first
time it was like we had gone to we were
supposed to go to a meeting together
because i'm codependent every time i
[ __ ]
date someone i'm like come to my
business meeting with me wait what
yeah i'm like oh these guys can probably
help your career too
um and then you're like why are you both
here they're like why are you both here
um but anyway so we went to the wrong
place we like his gps just took us to
like the beach accidentally that's weird
oh my god he played me so hard so then
we were just like at the beach with all
this time to kill
and we were like on the beach and he was
like rubbing my ass and stuff and it was
just like
okay so we're like romantically and then
when we made out there was no chemistry
oh [ __ ]
i was like well whatever we'll see you
know like but i was like i still was
like i'm not like he's trying to be my
boyfriend i don't know like but when you
kissed you weren't feeling it wasn't
like it never was really there like that
you know but i did feel so into him
because of these like little things he
was doing but i didn't really like fully
know that yet i was just in the process
of being played so we're like driving
back and i was like all right i just
want to say something i am like very
uncomfortable with this situation like
i'm down to like go like see how it goes
and like i wasn't like
like necessarily going to [ __ ] yeah
whatever but i was like
you know i am really i just got out of
this relationship this public
relationship with a comic i i really it
was very like intense and
like love him but very traumatic yeah it
was like a lot you're like not ready to
go and i really was not ready to do that
and i certainly wasn't ready to do like
a comedian thing publicly right and he
was like and i was like and i don't
trust you i just don't trust something
about you
and he was like well there's you can
trust me and um you know i'm also
apprehensive of dating a comic and stuff
but you know and i was like
yeah i was like i guess you're doing it
all saying it all like he was right
there was a formula exactly hitting all
the points but i'm not i'm like i'm
feeling it a little bit but i'm like
not but he's telling me like no i'm just
like
this is where we're at like this is just
the moment of like how we feel or
whatever i'm like okay
and it was nice he was a lot nicer than
my boyfriend before so i was like okay
aren't they had like nice things at a
house and a nice car and stuff
we drove back to his place
we were like hooking up and i was like i
don't think we should bang and he like
laughed and then i was like yeah you're
right let's just bang um but
i like whatever yeah so we bang and it
was like pretty good there was like
potential to have like good sex in the
future but it was like first bang is
always a dud yeah and it's just like
awkward it's like yeah
so someone's hitting someone's nose yeah
someone's bumping teeth yeah teeth my
teeth are touching your teeth you just
got the rhythms off you know
you don't know how the other moves how
the other likes is the first bang is
horrible it was better than i thought it
would be from the kiss right like but he
was so like kind of like distant and
weird it's like i get really like i'm
like a hippie like i really like open
the [ __ ] up even if i'm just [ __ ]
someone like yeah i'm like we're this is
going to be like a connection that's
like why i'm here
so
in the middle of it he gets a text i
don't even like pay attention or
whatever but later he's like oh that was
the actress texting me like how awkward
why would she but i'm like right but i
was like but it didn't even i was like
oh i was like yeah but even if she's
like a famous actress like i'm annie
letterman i'm hilarious
why would you i'm i'm shane making you
laugh [ __ ] like i just was like no like
it just didn't even like compute you're
like it was esther povick it was esther
his famous actress she's not gonna make
you laugh
the next morning
he goes
i said something about my ex-boyfriend
we were friends with him and i was very
recently out of the relationship so i
was still like talking about it because
i was still kind of in it i mean i was
like two weeks out probably three weeks
out
and um and i go
oh like he used to do this thing so like
thank you for not doing that like i
didn't get screamed at this morning like
to make breakfast or something and um
he was like um oh we'll have to make
sure the next guy you date isn't like
that
and i'm like this [ __ ]
says something like that why like
literally had this conversation one
million times so then i just like i'm
silent he drives him like he drops me
off like peace
um don't talk to him then he calls me
like he calls me like a day later or
whatever and he's like oh my god this
crazy thing happened he's like telling
me a story
like nothing
and then and i didn't say anything
because literally that's been my problem
in life i feel afraid to say like how i
feel yeah it builds up i blow up like
yeah and it's i that was another thing i
learned in the ayahuasca where it's like
boundaries can be very easy nice not a
big deal you can have everything you
want if you just like let people know
what you need that's it
and um
and then he takes me out on a date
he goes i'm going to take you on a date
or he goes i'm going to take you to my
friend's proposing to his friend at a
comedy club takes me to the comedy club
we watch his friend propose to a girl he
introduces me like the guy's like oh
your girl's like everyone's like
assuming i'm his girlfriend yeah right
it's like avoiding banging he's tired
he's busy he was working on something
but it was just like
he's like still hanging out with you but
there's no no sex but he's not hanging
out with me he's not hanging out with me
he's no he's looking
at you he's showing you around you are
me it sounds like he's bearding you yeah
like you're his beard right but he's
shot like like i'm hot i'm funny i'm
like yeah i'm his i'm his
soul patch that happens and then i
finally have a conversation with him i
go dude you're like making me feel bad
like i don't like this like you you
aren't like you're not you're you're
staying in touch with me you're too busy
to see me you're not giving me
compliments like i gave you like my body
like you need to like have a reaction to
that i'm not like i don't just like
i'm not like a drunk i'm not i'm sober
i'm here i'm like if i'm if you're gonna
like ask me to open up to and then i do
you need to like yeah acknowledge it and
whatever and he was like well i was
talking to my friend about how like hot
you are and how much i like you and
he's like i really want them to meet you
so he was like why don't you go bowling
with me and my friends and i was like i
mean i guess it's weird this is
so weird and i'm like my ex-boyfriend
was in town i [ __ ] him like i wasn't
like i was like exclusively like with
this guy you know but it was like it did
feel like it was i was like i better
[ __ ] my ex boyfriend before me i really
like you um let's you know the whole
boat but why am i meeting your friends
and bowling is like the worst date such
a nightmare it's like all so far
i know i'm not in my own shoes i can't
comfortably bowl with someone unless
i've been dating them for 10 years like
how bored do you have to be already
here's the thing about bowling here's
the thing about when you like when you
don't get a single
pin right yeah
and the walk of shame when you turn your
body around to face the crowd of people
who are like it's all right awesome it's
all right it's really a horrible feeling
you're right and this goes
this goes without saying he obviously
was a very good one
so okay so then i this is actually so
good i'm telling this story because it
leads into what we were just talking
about okay so then we go like we go to
the bowling thing and i'm before we go
bowling i'm like i'm annoyed with you
i'm at the i'm at the comedy show on the
phone with him like the night before and
i go i don't like this
this doesn't feel right i don't like
this
i was like you're like doing this push
and pull thing with me and now acting
like
i'm like
because he goes oh i just want to let
you know before we go on this date i am
still seeing other people that's what it
was that pissed me off
i went i like [ __ ] my explore for the
night before i'm like
i go yeah why are you telling me this
like what like i'm like you're the one
you're literally making me meet your
friends right now yeah why the moment
before are you like now by the way
it was just so and i'm like and now
you're treating me and he goes i haven't
done anything wrong i'm like you're
treating me like now i'm this needy girl
like you [ __ ] set this whole thing up
so then i go so we go bowling and i'm so
annoyed i'm like so mad the whole time
because i'm like i am a [ __ ] i'm like
do you know what my dms are dude like do
you know how sought after i am and
you're treating me like i'm this like
[ __ ] nothing hottie hottie also like
that just trying to get you get you
excited also annie did you did you throw
a couple strikes in there i did all
right
i always do okay really not consistent
but i i get in there sometimes i guess
you look like a good bowler
i look like i could stick my fingers in
all your holes
and make what needs to happen happen
knock down your pins [ __ ]
but anyway so then okay so at the end of
the thing i go i am
too good for this situation i like his
friends see us like fighting and stuff
like in this i go i need you you are the
boy and i am the girl i am not you are
not gonna just a weird thing for you to
say right now
just it's just awkward honestly
you're just delusional look like a titty
[ __ ] guys
um but so we go um so you say that to
him i say that to him and then when i
leave he texts me he's like do you want
to go on a date so i'm like okay but i'm
still so annoyed right so then i go do a
set at the in the main room at the
comedy store and i'm annoyed i do the
set but i'm like raw you know and i get
off stage and i see these two people
sitting there and they're like this guy
is glowing there's this man who's just
beautiful glowing man
and i just like high five him and then
later i was staying really late it was
like right after brodie died and it was
like a weird time so i was like chain
smoking cigarettes staying late this was
like
two weeks after and i'm like i just like
couldn't leave i felt really drawn to
stay at the club the one of the guys
that worked there was like oh my friend
wanted to meet you you high-fived him
and i was like oh really like
cool he goes you're his favorite
comedian he's been here twice and you're
his favorite and i was like oh he must
be trying to [ __ ] me or ask biester's
mom
and he was like which is not mutually
exclusive
maybe both of them maybe the parents
want to have a threesome
by the way
um
i miss his uh sexual attention
hi mary love you sorry
thank you for being a fan
[Laughter]
i'm gonna send you a shirt for free
sign up esther sucks
[Music]
anyone who drinks wine knows that the
options are limitless which is why
finding a wine i like can be a hit or
miss
i like to drink shard
and my god when i'm
at the trader joe's aisle i'm just like
nope can't decide i don't know how to do
it and i just blindly pick one i don't
even know if i'm gonna like it or not
but now that i'm a first leaf wine club
member i only george listen to this i
only get the hits that's because experts
at first leaf who know my personal
palette send wines i love right to my
door there's nothing
there's always something new to discover
first leaf is a wine club that curates
and ships wines that are perfect for you
and since they work with renowned wine
makers all over the world there's
virtually no limit to the variety of
wines you get to try not only this first
leaf introduce you to a ton of new wine
each box gets better when you rate the
wine you receive firstleaf learns more
about your palette here's a fun little
not so secret about first leaf they work
directly with winemakers which means you
get incredible wine 60
off of retail
that's unheard of
first leaf is so confident you'll love
the wine they have a they have a hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee if you
receive a bottle that isn't exactly what
you were hoping for first leaf will
credit your account join today and
you'll get six bottles of wine for 29.95
that's only 29.95
and free shipping on top of that just go
to try firstleaf.com
tuesday that's six bottles of wine for
29.95 and free shipping at try first
leaf dot com tuesday
let's talk about blue chew please
confidence can take you far in life and
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate and that's where blue chew
comes in blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them any time day
or night so you can plan ahead and be
ready for whatever opportunities arise
the process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluetooth tablets are made in the usa
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discreet package very
important i realize that bluetooth is a
male product but
i'm just gonna say this
i
come like this right like this if i were
a dude i'd be in trouble
yeah if i were a dude i would be on that
blue chew so fast yeah chew it you don't
have to swallow it literally you don't
have to swallow a pill you chew it and
you boil
boing boing so if you could benefit from
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use our promo
code tuesday at checkout just pay five
dollars shipping that's bluechew.com
promo code tuesday to receive your first
month free visit bluetooth.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank bluetooth for sponsoring
this podcast we are giving you free
boners you're welcome ladies bluetooth
is exclusively for men but the end
result is something you'll both enjoy so
get your man to sign up today no shame
in it we support it we love it
so he like and he was like you know but
i just like i'm not like available to
like be
a boyfriend or whatever and i'm just
like yeah but you are our actor yeah my
boyfriend you've been available like
you're my boyfriend why is my toothbrush
here like why are you
and then you know we ended up finally
just like
i can't remember how
it definitely there was a screaming on
the street because he wouldn't pay for
my parking i went to help him with
something something he wanted to do
i went to help him with it and i agreed
to help him that's fine but let's keep
in mind he doesn't pay me he doesn't um
do anything for me yeah financially and
this is helping him and his career i
would wake up and think about ideas for
him like i was so caught up in him
and uh but silver lining is
you know
the shaman showed up
yeah dude my the [ __ ] sound guy at
the comedy store once pulled me aside
and was like because he sits in this
booth that the god booth and looks down
he goes what the [ __ ] he goes you need
to get the [ __ ] away from this guy he
goes i see you come in you film his sets
you help him you do all this stuff for
him he's never done one thing for you
holy [ __ ] and i don't no he helps me too
and he goes no he doesn't and i go well
my sets are later he's tired he goes i'm
tired but when i'm working with someone
and it's an equal partnership i help
them was it danny yeah it was danny and
he goes this is your time this is this
is yours he's like do not give it to him
wow that's a great advice my first year
at the store danny i remember used to he
hated the guy i was dating and so he
hated me too it was funny that he was
nice to you
he was so much i love danny even more i
like him now though but you know i was
like a 21 year old well he probably saw
you being dragged into that world you
were a different girl i was very
different
throughout the studio
i just want to happily announce that my
[ __ ] works again yeah okay what was it
because of my story
please clap harder than that george no
no i didn't know it wasn't working can
someone help
wicks off really [ __ ] did someone
help me well no i think we were we were
talking about it we talked about it in
passing how i just like my i shut up
yourself and you're like oh i guess yeah
like i stopped even wanting to like
masturbate right okay so you just
weren't like
i stopped wanting to yeah it was just
this thing it just completely shut i
wouldn't even think i wouldn't look at
someone anybody else like there was
nothing in you know how normal that is
yeah but it lasted a long time how long
esther telling us was normal [ __ ]
weirdo driving me two years that's the
whole challenge
two years i did not masturbate do you
know how long that is the pandemic it's
it's the most stressful [ __ ] dude it's
stressful you're in a fight or flight
right now did you wake it up recently is
that why i woke up the [ __ ] up it was
that episode where you touched her
i took one look at you in this getup and
my [ __ ] woke up what if it was wet when
she got up there's a puddle
how happy would you be
would you leave dave
you'd throw the the tube to the wind
i wonder if we could work something now
like where i dave and iris you and bobby
are you at me and dave our unit but
there's like swapping going on because i
feel like dave and bobby could have some
fun just hanging out oh they've been
it wasn't a date it was like a lifestyle
wait a second so we're not pineapples
can you guys videotape
i would mystery science theater it
actually sounds great
now we should hang out more we are we
pineappling
are we swinging
yes but you and i are being sexual and
the guys are playing video games
okay but they're both a little
they could no
i think bobby bobby would you'd be be
careful dave because bobby would dave
wouldn't not i don't think dave would
even no dave is very todd what's up
boundaries though because no todd would
not i know todd doesn't seem like he
would have a straight boy
so then maybe
it does need to be
uh
okay there's some sort of here's what
i'm saying
pressure my boyfriend but does dave does
dave like if let's say like judd avatar
was like dave
no dave is not dave is like very
straight yeah
no but it's not that he's not straight
it's how susceptible because bobby's
really the only one we're saying would
just enjoy it enjoy it fully but well
yeah very straight but he does have a
big brother we always say like he has he
has a big brother complex and i have a
big sister complex like we're both is
that why he has long hair and you dress
like a boy
like he if there's like an older like
guy he'll he does get really like
excited about feeling like a brother
with someone he gets like really excited
do you guys do this like they get really
excited to hang out with like a cool guy
um bobby in a very submissive way he
does i feel like dave would like dave is
when like when bobby comes up dave is
like oh bobby's cool like he's like
wants to play with bobby i guess yeah
bobby can be like that sometimes todd
just hangs back and the cool people come
to him
yeah true todd okay so todd's having his
10-year high school reunion
he's so young
oh my god you're a child monster
i was literally sucking a dick between
the towers i was like i was a grown-up
when that happened um
he was born the year kirkland died
anyway
so oh my god
like that guy that baby is like older
than my boyfriend
that baby's like well over there go to
the reunion
you gotta go but he said but he
he posted and he goes hey sorry guys i'm
not gonna um i know that you guys know
i'm friends with olivia munn but i'm not
gonna be able she's not gonna be able to
come i know you guys were hoping she
would she's pregnant so uh i'll try to
get one of my other celebrity friends
again oh no goes hey guys because he was
voted class comedian so he goes hey guys
it's class comedian here and then he
just says the olympian thing and then he
posts the thing in the daily mail of him
with olivia munn
todd got in a picture and
uh paparazzi a paparazzi
picture where i was there but i was like
behind the car so it literally looks
like olivia munn is driving invading
your voice dating my boyfriend but also
like
like bought a plant that's in the front
seat so he's got to sit in the back or
something you know like there's a reason
he's in the back but he's holding my dog
my dog and my boyfriend were in the
picture it was so funny
but and then he posted that picture it's
literally the funniest thing oh my gosh
we're so all over the place today but
there's so much like i'm like enjoying
it but i'm like wait what was that like
wait can i tell you though that i saw
him lay out the guy
that played me i saw him lay out how to
get a girl on a podcast okay so that's
what trump and it was all the same
shut up yeah cause i'm not sure i don't
give a [ __ ] about him i'm fine when i
see him stop it
tell us okay
he goes um when a guy
um or when a girl likes you never like
ask her on a date or anything so hang on
one second you just heard him on a
podcast there was a clip that some i
don't follow him yeah and by the way
this person love and light like legit
yeah
when i see him it's like ha ha fun
we've done enough like it's just it's
over it's not yeah it's not even bad i
think he is just like uh
he's got troubles and he's has a way of
getting people that i don't even think
he means to do it yeah people in
and that's just how it is so like some
kid calls it and then so he's like
okay if you want to get out of the
friend zone you have to
make them know about another girl that's
really into you yeah
yeah okay and then like have her like
help you with the girl shut up and then
yeah and then have like show her all the
texts this is like the oj book if i did
it
it's like this one keep going the factor
still obsessed with oj i've moved on to
a new american tragedy
oh my god
okay keep going i can't remember there
was like some other thing but it was
like and the panties will drop or
whatever it's just like i hate that [ __ ]
it's just so [ __ ] annoying because
it's like i knew it was happening i was
denying it the whole time like i'm
telling you like a year later i was like
here's my issue if you knew you weren't
gonna be my boyfriend don't come at me
as a boyfriend i don't [ __ ] care i
wasn't trying to be your girlfriend
you played me you were dishonest with me
and that [ __ ] i'm never getting over
that
like in this friendship i'm always gonna
need another apology like it's never
gonna be enough and he was like well i
mean um he's like i couldn't not [ __ ]
you i was just like so into you like
it's like no
like [ __ ] you i cuz i would have been
down if he was clear about it too i
probably would have just banged him and
it would have i mean
get it out of the way the fact that he
even
has
rules or bullet points or a [ __ ]
powerpoint presentation
how to [ __ ] get a woman to
fall for you and you not reciprocate is
sociopathic that doesn't seem good yeah
oh no
so i'm watching uh annie spinning around
round round and round i do see a nipple
oh my god
um todd's hat back on but not your top
okay no we'll just blur it the whole
episode shut up
well i'm doing you guys know i'm doing a
hustler shoot right well you're making
up for the you're making up for the miss
lingerie episode this is what we get no
i'm gonna do lingerie when you guys
least expect it
you guys are gonna look like [ __ ] and
i'm gonna come in so hot when you least
expect it makes me feel like at midnight
tonight my doorbell's gonna rain oh you
wish [ __ ] i love how it's always
something where you're getting banged
oh my worst nightmare all these girls
come over and finger me
[Applause]
wait what's your hustler shoot tell us
what i'm doing they're doing a six page
shoot on me spread
um and like i don't have to be naked or
anything but of course um i'm trying to
figure it out but i do want to
i know this is for offline but i do want
to get serious about pinning
an edible sleepover night
a vegas night there's another thing i
want to do which i've talked to you guys
about like i'm manifesting i want us to
go to like a malibu boot camp retreat
together okay i'm down here i've got
wait is that exercise or what kind of
boot camp yeah oh please i've got big
plans it's just rehab for you
it's already an intervention you've
started for yourself
but i use a weed addict help i do want
to we haven't quite talked about the
bobby lee look and i would love to talk
about it it's such a good look i think
that esther and i have both
used at points in our lives yeah i think
that bobby is sort of a style icon he
never goes with trends he likes what he
likes and he just flies with it i love
that about him same yeah it's like i
yesterday like my mom
he wore
head to toe different tones of green
like head to toe
and
he was like ma do i look good she's like
you look like a grasshopper
and he went and he was just i don't know
he just gets it some people have it
internally to like be that
kind of like
fashionable he has the instincts yes and
his body and everything looks good on
him i know yeah he really is cool yeah
he really is cool i l it's so true
it's it's hard for a comedian
to look cool and close like that's not
common
but he has his own thing going on why
did you pick
the glasses the beanie i feel like is
this like this is his iconic look yeah i
feel like i mean this
jersey i feel like he's worn a couple
times on bad friends he likes a good um
comfortable camo are his clothes tight
on you
not really here are the pants
are dave's tight on you
i wish they were bigger
but no his clothes fit me perfectly
that's why we share clothes i mean i i
guess i him and i wrestle similarly
so similarly who took from who
we take from each other because some
there are some things that i buy that
he's like i [ __ ] love that let me
have that and we fight
we tussle
and then we both end up wearing it
but um he does take from my closet a lot
because i have some really cool vintage
tees too yeah you do because i used to
live on 4th street close to 4th street
in long beach and they have the best
vintage stuff there so he would always
take my [ __ ] so it's like we're half
half on the good vintage t-shirts this
is i i was dave actually texted me
information about my outfit this morning
i have not read it
and i should read it to you guys dave
was actually trying to help me take that
guy on a shop remember he was trying to
find the place to go shopping oh yeah
dave was dave was an accomplice oh my
god he's so pathetic okay he said the
shirt is a is wardrobe from a music
video that he helped out on years ago
that his friend mike directed and the
video is based on a chapter from the
book infinite jess which takes place
at a fictional tennis academy so this is
a tennis the hat is a red sox hat but
featuring their secondary logo
and the pants are uniqlo and the belt is
his backup belt because he can't find
his favorite belt ever since my dad
borrowed it your dad borrowed his belt
and the sock oh i forgot this sock dave
is a sock guy yeah my dad dave keeps
saying that he thinks my dad stole his
belt
and i asked my dad and i don't think i
got a clear answer i genuinely don't
know but when my dad was visiting he
forgot about
and then there's no belt yeah it could
just be in your room
totally
you guys it's been sort of a rough week
bobby um bobby woke up and he was really
bummed he was like norm passed away
and um i think what's sad is that like
sort of no one knew and he feels as
though like
no one knew he was sick yeah no one
knows i think that's gangster it is
pretty gangster yeah
i
look i respect anyone's decision on how
to handle things i think it would be
gangster to share a gangster not to
share but i also feel like the reason i
this is my theory obviously i don't know
the reason he was able to live for nine
years with it is because
his identity wasn't i'm like a cancer
guy like if you have that identity and
people are saying that to you you're
gonna get i i believe that you will
you're convincing yourself to get sicker
does anyone know what kind of cancer he
had
no
yeah it's really sad he's definitely
like
the comedian's comedian like i feel like
every year he's like your favorite
comedian his favorite comedian and he's
probably you're like he's just i
i feel like i had
a weird
do you know about my i had like a weird
relationship with norm mcdonald's
tell me we talked about this maybe i
don't know remind me i feel like you
know this
it was like weird for a while
he's so much he's my dad's favorite and
he's so much like my dad
gambling oh he wanted to bang me
no but when i so years ago i did last
comic standing and the judges were
roseanne barr
awayans i never know which one
and that doesn't make me racist please
lord
hashtag not racist okay
i feel like i've talked about this
before and norm mcdonald was one of the
judges and when we did the show the
producers it was produced by wanda sykes
and her producing partner this woman
page horse who's awesome and wanda and
paige were like you guys
we're producing last comic standing our
way this is a comedian's er like this is
safe a space safe space for communities
this isn't like american idol where no
one's gonna like tear you down it's
gonna be all constructive positive and
so like great i go out i do my first set
the judges like me like i go to the next
round
and then i'm at my second taping and i
was new to comedy so i didn't really
have like a second five minutes
i don't know
maybe 2013.
i really don't know i was just testing
yeah make sure if you were really new
i wasn't that new
um
and so i do my second set and it's i
it's like obviously not as good as the
first one and like roseanne and like the
first two judges are like
they're like positive right because
that's what and then norm
hits me out of nowhere
with like i this is the biggest
disappointment of my night
and i'm like
i'm so close like your dad i'm so caught
off guard and then he starts like
rewording my joke
like trying to like fix it and for some
reason i just go straight to like
teenager
teenage girl fight back mode like how i
was when i was younger and i was just
like
if i just went out after him i was like
really norm like i'm the biggest
disappointment of your night like [ __ ]
you like you might then that i
you must have a great life yeah and
you're rewording my jokes if that makes
any sense like you know i don't need to
hear this from my dad's favorite
comedian like i just went off on him and
the audience i like that when you were
going after you still complimented him
but i was so worked up and i was so
angry and i just like walked off the
stage like i didn't do my exit interview
i just left and we filmed this on the
studio a lot at universal and so i like
busted out the doors and was wandering
around the lot and i just sat on a golf
cart
and i called dave and dave is i told
dave everything that happened and dave
is like
what the [ __ ] did you do dave's like no
it's so good you did that dave's like
norm macdonald is a [ __ ] genius he
was trying to help you he liked you he's
everyone's favorite comedian like what
have you done
and dave made me feel so bad and then i
called my parents and told him
everything and my parents just start
laughing hysterically they're like oh
that's who you really are
and they're like he got a taste to be
like how it really is because that's how
i treated my uncles when i was young i
was always like [ __ ] you fight back
and so that like for years like oh and
then that week i called my agents and
was like whatever you do like please
have them cut this out please please
please cause dave i got it in my head
this is gonna like make everyone hate me
because i'm fighting them no it's so
likeable yeah that is like but i'm
fighting the most beloved guy in comedy
yeah but he was a dick
i don't know anyway so they're like they
my agents call the producers like they
call me back like don't worry it's never
going to air like they don't they don't
want to air whatever it doesn't air so
for years i'm walking around carrying
this like nor mcdonald hates me i hate
him can we do we have a club
i've never seen it i've tried i've tried
to dig it up i'm i'm like he hates me i
hate him like this is this thing like
he's ever he's the golden child of
comedy and i have this beef with him
then
three years later my my manager at the
time email is like oh there's a dropout
to open irvine this weekend for norm
mcdonald like okay
so i go i walk in the green room like
hey norm
like you know sorry about like our fight
he's like what
he's like why would i fight with you
what are you talking about
and he didn't remember anything
he was and he was so nice and it was
great and i i it was just i'm so
grateful that like instead of holding on
to that forever like i got to like
realize that it was absolutely nothing i
know it's so funny this was nine years
ago and you were like he had just gotten
his cancer diagnosis and you walk in
you're like sorry that i fought when he
was like i'm going through something
but he really was like such a nice guy
and so funny and then also i watched his
set that night and i genuinely was like
[ __ ] these are good jokes like the guys
got it i know that's like everyone's so
funny for you to learn that later i know
but yeah that's
rest in peace i'm it's very sad and he's
a [ __ ] hero obviously i
have been
trying to look at death this is what
i've been like learning from some of the
stuff i've been doing
as you have a contract in the universe
of how long you're going to be here
and that's just people's contract and
it's like kind of not your business when
they go or when they stay and it's been
helping me a lot with people's
deaths where i just go okay like this
was their time yeah because there isn't
another option yeah so it's like why
you fight it well on this and like it
wasn't suicide and it wasn't fentanyl
and it's like
thank you norm
yeah thank you
i thought the lingerie one is um we
should do it again it was so stupid but
it also brought out
turns out when esther and i are in
lingerie it brings out something in you
well you were looking
really good
yeah
i think esther still was like a maid
that's the more surprising part not the
sexy part
no but i did what you taught me to do
annie draw my boobs in
i do think we should do lingerie again i
would like another oh you know what dave
was totally an [ __ ] to me he was like
kalila's what did what we call she
understood the assignment
no but hers was like cat ears too wasn't
it you both were like wearing and
she i thought it was halloween i was
like is this a [ __ ] i was like is this
[ __ ] halloween what's the theme we're
going reverse here because for halloween
we're going to dress as conair right
that's right hell yeah well we kind of
are now
yeah i've got a game okay let's do this
dress like your man episode okay so we
want to see how many of the greatest guy
movies you guys have actually seen okay
i'm just going to tell you guys
esther has never seen a movie and
because uh
you know this could be subjective so we
just went with the the top list on
google best guy movies of all time so if
google says it it's nothing these are
the real ones the godfather
yes no
she has yelled at her godfather though
so it's nor macdonald we've seen it
all right die hard no yes
we've all experienced it on stage some
of us with the cpap machine okay
scarface no yes
esther is gonna have a scarface after
she [ __ ] this up fight club yes
i've i know i these are like
no i've never like dated the right guy
that made me watch these i've seen like
no country for old men like i've seen
like that is a great one yeah yeah i've
seen all the ones my dad made me watch
okay rocky
no yes when your dad was like i want you
to see this movie called no country for
old men do you think did you think it
was like aarp propaganda
where he's gonna be like give all your
money to your father
rocky was a big one for me
my new game is uh let's keep going until
esther gets one okay
i love that this game is like have you
seen all of the movies how are these guy
movies yeah this is sexist george it's
on google so have you seen 13 going on
i see you guys don't care about us it's
not that wonderful about you
i have seen that one well and you love
it
the terminator
yes did you call it the turbinator
that sounds like a porn i've seen before
let's keep going we were making fun of
us
they're still out of zero it's not about
me annie uh the good the bad and the
ugly no yes i also made a remake of it
todd did a whole thing in the beginning
of the pandemic is that our podcast the
good the bad the oh my god is that the
name
lock stock and two smoking barriers yeah
no yes
wow this is getting crazy here's your
last chance uh saving she knows about
stocks she's like stop saving private
ryan esther saving private ryan where
did they put the heroine i have only two
parts of it i don't know what my dad was
watching on hbo i'd never watched the
whole wow we're at a zero george sturdy
harry no yes i've seen dirty harry and
my friend had a really good joke about
it he said he went home with clint
eastwood's daughter this is nick
maritado he went he went home because he
saw his daughter and he's like and i
could tell it was her because she had a
dirty hairy [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what's that one oh gran torino i seen
that one again only the racist one yeah
where he calls her a dragon mom that's
her favorite she thinks it's like she
thinks it's a comedy she like cracks
options it's so funny
wait hang on go go keep going still at a
zero good fellas good fellas come on
how did you know how to open a door and
if a guy likes you is that the one where
sharon stone blows him no that's casino
yeah that's yeah that's casino no i
haven't here we go come on come on
national lampoon's animal house of
course
yeah what what's the scene what's the
famous scene cupid draw back your bow
when he's eating lunch
i don't like we have to give a diet or
else we're gonna keep yeah
you guys
today was so fun i felt like i could go
for another three hours with you
i i'm sorry she did not take blue chews
so that is a big deal
i am so happy that three of us could all
be together i know people have been sad
that we're it's not always like that but
it will be more and more when did you
you just started to sound like an
actress this is the first time and she
was like this has been so fun i love
being with you guys we are here loving
each other
like each other wait did you say it
right now we love each other
come on esther get with the old sperm
old [ __ ] we're old sperm we're slugs
kalila played with slugs when she was
little and he called it that i am an
actual slug and here we are the slugs
were born i don't know
someone told me that on the episode i
wasn't on that you guys said we are
changing the name again we're just going
to say that forever
who cares okay for now we're trash
tuesday we're kalylah annie and esther
and we will see you [ __ ] next week
hell yeah
[Music]
you